a familiar tale of a wooden boy is seen
in a whole new light through the
Visionary imagination of one of the
greatest living horde directors
2022 has seen a bevy of amazing
stop-motion animated movies and closing
off this year of stop-motion Madness is
possibly the most exciting project of
them all as Academy Award winner
Guillermo del Toro puts his own spin on
the classic 1883 Carlo collodi novel
Pinocchio the well-known story has seen
multiple adaptations throughout the
decades most notably Walt Disney's
beloved 1940 version still Del Toro
seemed to be offering a completely new
vision of this classic tale that will
surely take audiences by surprise
this is my Pinocchio
Guillermo del Toro is best known for his
Lush array of genre films such as Pan's
Labyrinth Crimson Peak Hellboy and the
best pitcher winning the shape of water
he has had his eyes on the famous wooden
character Pinocchio for some time
originally announced back in 2008 Del
Toro has not only been in love with the
Pinocchio story itself but has always
envisioned it as an animated feature and
now Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio is
set for release in Select theaters
throughout November 2022 but will be
available to stream on Netflix on
December 9th 2022. its World premiere
came on October 15 2022 at the BFI
London Film Festival which will be
followed by the animationist film
festival on the 29th and an official U.S
Premiere at AFI Fest on November 5th the
film was seen a troubled production over
the past few years as multiple release
dates have been set and reworked
alongside fellow upcoming stop-motion
Netflix film Wendell and wild Guillermo
del Toro's Pinocchio was initially
slated for release sometime in 2021. the
film along with several other
high-profile Netflix animated projects
were moved to 2022 with Netflix CEO 10
at sarandos revealing that the company
has plans to release up to six animated
features a year but that's nothing
compared to the film's earlier troubles
originally intended to be released in
2013 or 2014. the film went through
several years of development tell as no
studio is willing to put up the finances
to produce it things got so out of hand
that the director canceled the ambitious
project even after getting Over the
Garden Wall Creator Patrick McHale is a
screenwriter thankfully in 2018 Netflix
came to the rescue in greenlit the film
the plot of Guillermo del Toro's
Pinocchio while following the general
outline of the classic story seems to
have more in store in its setting and
presentation description of the film
given by a tweet from Netflix film reads
set during the rise of fascism and
Mussolini's Italy Pinocchio is a story
of love and Disobedience as Pinocchio
struggles to live up to his father's
expectations this setting deviating from
the fairy tale World audiences are
accustomed to is in line with del Toro's
dark Fantastical Vision staying more
faithful to the original Carlo colodi
tale The Adventurous of Pinocchio which
the director described tribes as having
a far more perverse and spooky and
semi-necrophilia vibe to it in certain
aspects one element it will share with
the Disney classic is that del Toro's
film is set to be a musical writing both
the musical numbers and scoring the film
is Alexander de Spa this will be
display's second time working with Del
Toro after winning an Academy Award for
his work on the shape of water in 2017.
it will also be displayed's third
stop-motion film I mean worked with
director Wes Anderson and being
nominated for Academy Awards for the
musical scores of both 2009's Fantastic
Mr Fox and 2018's Isle of dogs
Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio will see
a star-studded cast take on these
classic characters but voicing the
titular role is newcomer Gregory Mann oh
what a day what a day man's time working
on the project was a positive one at the
film's BFI London Film Festival Premiere
he talked about the director to hey you
guys saying quote he's incredible I mean
he's just as good as he sounds he's
amazing to work with as well he's so
kind and he brings such a nice spirit to
the recording studio or the set and he
really made me look at the lines and
look at them into deeper context playing
as Pinocchio's closest allies the
cricket and Geppetto are Ewan McGregor
and David Bradley respectively alongside
them are Christoph Waltz as the
villainous count Volpe Kate Blanchett
says the monkey Puppeteer spazatura Ron
Perlman as the podesta Finn wolfhard as
the podesta's son Candlewick until the
Swinton as the Wood Sprite who gives
Pinocchio life Tim Blake Nelson John
Turturro and Byrne Gorman round out the
cast in unknown roles Netflix has
currently released two trailers for
Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio the first
released in January 2022 acts as a brief
teaser where Ewan McGregor's crickets or
Sebastian J Cricket as he calls himself
prepares to write something while
telling the audience an interesting fact
I lived
lived in the heart of the wooden boy
whether this is meant to be taken
literally or this version of the cricket
will stand as a representation of
Pinocchio's Hearts rather than his
conscience is yet to be seen still the
teaser excited viewers for what was to
come just from the beautiful look alone
a full film trailer was released in Late
July 2022. in it we see Geppetto who
appears to have lost a child of his own
build and pieced together Pinocchio from
there were treated to a truth Beast for
the eyes as Pinocchio goes about the
town meets both good and evil faces and
warmly interacts with Geppetto it's hard
not to get swept up in the overwhelming
Splendor of the animation on display
from the beautifully textured and
designed characters to the Grand sets to
the outstanding visual effects this
trailer alone proves why the dazzling
art form of stop-motion animation will
never truly die out top it off with a
sweeping musical score and you can count
us in for whatever Guillermo del Toro
has in store
foreign
[Music]